Here is the worst part about the Olympics opening ceremony.
No, it isn't that they were mocking Christianity,
cause let's be honest, there is nothing new about that.
It's getting boring at this point.
Madonna was doing it back when she was really popular,
and she's old enough to be my grandma,
so were used to it. The worst part is this,
that is a small child. And watching that whole performance,
watching the outfits, watching the innuendos,
watching the dance moves,
anyone who's honest can admit that that is no place for a child.
How did this child get there?
Like, who are the adults in charge of making sure they are safe?
If this child has been put in this situation,
what other situations have they been put in?
A lot of people saying that they wouldn't let their children watch it
now, which I agree with.
But can we address the fact that there is a child in the performance
involved with these adults?
As Christians,
I think we get really defensive about our beliefs and about Christ,
as we should. But the truth is that our faith is not that fragile.
It has been mocked so many times and to the point where I'm just like
over it. It's old,
it's boring.
It doesn't even make me angry anymore because I just don't care.
It's boring. But if you really study the life of Jesus Christ himself,
you'll see that he is very clear on What he thinks of people
who put children in dangerous situations.
I think the most disturbing thing about western culture right now
is the way that we treat children.
They are the most vulnerable,
they are the most likely to be hurt and taken advantage of,
and yet they are at the very bottom of the list of our priorities.
If you are a Christian, if you are a religious person,
if you are a decent person in general,
that is what should really offend you.